madame monsieur bonsoir au rwanda c'est
plus que jamais le voyage au bout de
l'enfer des milliers d'habitants de
kigali fui en effet la capitale par
crainte de nouveaux massacres les
rebelles devrait en effet prendre le
contrôle de kigali dans les tout
prochains jours
jeudi après demain notre magazine envoyé
spécial diffusera un document réalisé
par nos confrères de l'agencé capa un
document tourné dans un orphelinat de
kigali tenu tant bien que mal par un
coopérant français marc b terre qui a
refusé d'abandonner ses enfants dans une
ville ravagée par la guerre civile
après six semaines de cauchemar
kigali est aujourd'hui transformé en un
gigantesque camp de réfugiés
plus de 4000 personnes s'entassent dans
cet hôpital du centre ville sans eau
sans électricité
ceux qui ont échappé au massacre commis
par les milices extrémistes hutu sont
maintenant victimes des bombardements
aveugles des artilleurs du front
patriotique rwandais qui resserre son
étau autour de la ville partout les
mêmes témoignages la même détresse
cette femme a perdu un enfant dans les
bombardements les trois autres sont ici
grièvement blessé
dehors les massacres continuent les
miliciens hutus saccagent la ville à la
recherche des derniers tout si vivant
qui se terre dans kigali
en attendant les renforts promis par le
conseil de sécurité
les quelques casques bleus présents
protège du mieux qu'ils peuvent des
poches de populations civiles où se sont
réfugiés indistinctement hutus et tutsis
question que peuvent faire les casques
bleus en cas d' attaque massive dès
turcs
on espère bien qu ils n'attaqueront pas
ça on l'espère bien
on a bien réussi à protéger ces gens
jusqu'à maintenant on va continuer on
continuera les protéger jusqu'à ce que
les choses aillent mieux
nous sommes en discussion permanente
avec tous ces gens c'est une question de
négociation dans le centre-ville dévasté
70 orphelins vivent retranchés à
l'intérieur de leur foyer ils en sont
réduits à creuser un abri à même le sol
ils ne doivent la vie sauve qu'à la
présence continue à leurs côtés de mark
v terre le responsable de cet orphelinat
aux premières heures des massacres alors
que les militaires français venaient
l'évacuer mark webber a refusé
d'abandonner les enfants ils partagent
désormais leur sort
on est tellement menacée tous les jours
on sait jamais on ne sait jamais sans
être si on va passer la nuit
si on va pas nous
vous forcer les portes alors on est on
est maîtres attendu à l'autre bout du
centre ville
le père blanchard vit lui aussi
retranché dans sa paroisse le
missionnaire vivant au rwanda depuis 30
ans a ouvert son église à des centaines
de réfugiés lorsque les massacres ont
éclaté le lendemain militaire et
munitions donc forcer les portes
quinze personnes ont été tuées sous ses
yeux j'ai vu des gens tuaient tantôt par
balles tantôt par coups de couteau
tantôt par coups de gourdin c'était
insoutenable
on en ressort soi-même profondément
meurtri